múltiples documentos confidenciales
fueron hallados en la biblioteca
personal del presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden el año pasado fue en
esta casa de Donald Trump en mara lago
donde también se encontraron documentos
que supuestamente pertenecían a los
archivos nacionales
Qué son los archivos nacionales el sitio
web oficial de los archivos nacionales
los define como la colección de
documentos del gobierno de Estados
Unidos que recoge acontecimientos
importantes de la historia
estadounidense más del 95% de los
registros de los archivos están
desclasificados y por lo tanto abiertos
al público pero algunos son clasificados
lo que significa que contienen
información sensible que requiere
autorización de seguridad Cuáles son los
tipos de clasificación
Existen tres niveles de clasificación
del nivel más bajo al nivel más alto
confidencial secreto y top Secret en
este caso podría tratarse de documentos
que contengan planes vitales para la
defensa nacional o información sensible
Cómo deben tratarse los documentos
clasificados
la ley estadounidense Establece que los
documentos gubernamentales deben
entregarse a los archivos nacionales una
vez que un presidente o funcionario
abandona su cargo si el interesado se
opone a la investigación o se niega a
entregar los documentos como ocurrió con
Donald Trump en 2021 Entonces el
incidente se convierte en un asunto
penal